I I always resist when Bank rates senior
industry and analyst says uh suggesting
that people aren't cutting back and
using credit cards is it's because of
the rising cost of inflation no they're
not cutting back to offset inflation
duper that's what's really going on and
so you know and I get it I it's not fair
I don't like inflation I don't want that
to take your check away from you but
don't be a victim
you're not a victim you're a victim of
the person in your mirror and the idea
here's here's another plan if you think
getting into debt to maintain your
lifestyle is going to maintain your
lifestyle there's an end to that there's
a mathematical into that it eventually
comes in but it's a boomerang comes back
around smacks you in the head and says
hey dummy